allez c'est parti n'a cessé de c'est sûr
et j'espère vous n'avez pas voté
castaldi attention kelly vdo belmas trop
forte libido belli ça passe pour
l'instant c'est pas mal c'est pas mal
vous êtes là mais l'idée novelli c'est
le côté écoutez commençait sérieusement
à me faire chier
vas-y alors allez vous connaissez oui
bien sûr comment s'appelle qui quoique
suisse et je me disais belmont misère
vas-y magazine poids de bouteilles
attention c'est parti je peux rester
huit heures à faire ce jour d'être
flatteur sur des fines bâti ma chérie
doucement dell fait main c'est trop fort
trop fort tu n'es pas là que kelly tu
passes bernard montiel
vous connaissez oui bah non bien sûr
vous deviez résumer sa carrière en un
mot vidéo gag pas
[Rires]
bon c'est pas prenez votre truc je peux
pas tout faire
prends ton petit truc taille at on doit
pas qu'à moi qui les consomme à elle en
rigole voilà ça s'est vu remettre avec
non kelly king cité prévôtoise expliqué
nicolas pernikoff vous connaissez les
grands patrons de france télévisions
bien sûr c'est bien sûr et là je veux tu
cela
il est content j'espère vous avez mis
j'ai permis comme sonné après la finale
pour l'instant là bas si banny beau
gosse
soit qu'il est tombé tomber alors sur
gilles verdez jésus mais on a mûri cause
le stress et le vampire de denner s'est
levé n'y a pas de menace c'est là il ya
une finale entre gilles verdez et
nicolas pernikoff pour se qualifier
allez allez allez l'ady gil même avec un
peu plus de tension s'est passé mondial
s'est pas installée la war sur pernikoff
[Applaudissements]
la finale maintenant nicolas pernikoff
jimoh redouane et moi c'est par là
attention c'est parti
vous voyez vous pouvez vous joindre
votre votre bouteille pourrait choisir
quelqu'un qui m'aurait dois t'avouer
c'est parti rappelle que vous jouez chez
vous pour savoir qui va gagner
là il y aura alors à chaque fois je vous
dis quand on est quatre il y aura un
éliminé à chaque fois je repars avec le
smartphone vont devoir voter près d'1
éliminé à chaque fois c'est chaud ça
c'est parti vas-y redouane elle n'est
pas nulle
ça peut pas si simple pensée ça peut
passer il y aura un éliminé à chaque
fois que j'ai mangé mon y aura un
éliminé à chaque fois
l'atr autant sa famille l'a forcé à
limoges
la force n'a pour seul un coup de filet
mamie aulas
on avait peine à sortir
non mais non gens mais je vais faire mon
coup je vais faire beaucoup attention
des +3 nicolas muller nikov mais dont
les broderies nicholas evans terminera
les résines et nicolas pas un signe que
larry pense à france télé prince télé
pense pas ça l'à beaucoup les bienvenus
ébéniste on a trouvé on a trouvé un
emploi nouveau champion nicolas ce qu'on
peut prendre votre petit truc et merci
merci nico avait elle met de l'autre
côté mais je peux pas tout faire non
plus à moi on est sûr on est sûr de lui
plaît beaucoup mais ce qu'on peut
enlever votre bouteille qu'on est sûrs
du plateau où en est ce une journée sur
deux pattes au japon y aura un bain
éliminer les uns élimine à chaque fois
je sais qu'il va gagner c'est bon je
suis quand même arrivé à temps gelé au
maître voilà positionne à la 90e
les douanes je quitte la rue immédiate à
son final antoine nicolas pernikoff et
moi c'est en deux points nicolas tu veux
faire un petit pari entre non non c'est
pas la même attente est hyper sont ces
magnifiques à 8 heures c'est pas bon
c'est pas moche merci nicolas battu chez
trident tu vois bien que comment ça se
fait que ça c'est que ça oui c'est vrai
mais si tu triches choisi
aussi j'ai mes limites vas-y nicolas
pour le premier point aux jeux sont
forts à pourquoi il ya plusieurs points
là on a dit sûr que je suis gentil en
plus ça tambour ou jamais mais j'ai de
plus en plus faire payer 0 pour la
deuxième phase il rappelle que vous
pouvez encore paris sur twitter entre
nicolas et moi ok ok les belles années
moussa dois tu peux pas tarder à vous
êtes là vous verrez fils tu triches pas
je vais être honnête si je marchais même
pas mal bon lancer si je gagne c'est
pour mieux la pression sur les épaules
de cyril lemieux
[Applaudissements]
cette affaire